file this under better late than never
pope francis commemorated the centenary
of the slaughter of armenians
calling the massacre by the ottoman
turks the first genocide of the 20th
century
francis urged international
organizations to formally recognize the
armenian genocide in order to prevent
such horrors from repeating themselves
francis's comments caused immediate
outcry from turkish leaders
the turkish foreign minister took to
twitter saying the pope's statement
which is far from historic and legal
truth is
unacceptable religious positions are not
places where unfounded claims are made
and hatred is stirred turkey went on to
recall its ambassadors for consultations
and summon the vatican's envoy all right
so we're only a couple days from the
100th anniversary of the beginning of
the armenian genocide now obviously the
church had never acknowledged it before
many western countries still haven't
acknowledged it
but the reason i want to do this story
was because i think this pope
is actually pretty pretty good like this
is a good pope
he's done some stuff with about gay
people i know it's not perfect yet
but he's done a little something it take
these these institutions are big it
takes a long time to drag in there
he's done a lot of stuff with with
homeless people he's trying to do
something good and this strikes me as
another
good thing that he's trying to
acknowledge history
and and sort of move forward what do you
think about this pope um i do think he's
the coolest pope thus far
yeah so i'm with you on that but it is
something where
um i do think ultimately
the turkish ambassador's words really
kind of rung true for me when he said
yeah when he said the religious office
is not the place
to take sides or push
an agenda especially when it's one that
is talking about the loss of lives when
you make one
more important than the other
inadvertent just by use of language
i can understand if i were a citizen of
that country being
taken aback or feeling slighted
right by that but should we worry about
the the turks feeling slighted if it's
what
if 1.5 million armenians were killed
here's the thing i guess this goes to
your point about politics and religion
i don't think they're bad fellows i just
think ultimately they're not they'll
i do think for example when you brought
up oh he's done great well not great
things great things in terms of the
catholic church yeah
it turns out right it's all slow and
it's all slow and it's like huge step
for
that kind of institution you're
absolutely right but i also think that
at the end of the day it's like
when you start politicking you end up
creating more dividing lines than you do
uniting ones sometimes
because it's it's why politicians really
aren't necessarily smart people they're
just really good
or likable people right you can vote for
them
ideas may be stupid whereas a religious
organization
especially one as prevalent as the
catholic church to my
my my opinions yeah they need to keep
they
sell doing the church thing and i'm
gonna be over here doing mine
you just wanna keep handing out wafers
yeah give up give out the grape juice
and the
little bit of bread and i'm gonna be
over here doing my thing
but i don't think that's i don't think
those are the two things that should
meet up right so now jacqueline if i
know one thing about you it's that you
love religion
and you love popes so how do you feel
how do you feel about this pope in
general somebody that's
trying to change things yeah i mean i i
think this is one good thing that he's
done
so i mean like he's done some good
things there are some things to do that
i don't agree with but this is
definitely one of the more positive
things and the quote that you mentioned
i think
yeah ideally that'd be great but i feel
like that's exactly what religion is for
it's a place where people do that
i think that's what comedy is where you
do that not not well
it's a financial ideally ideally that
would be the case but it's it's often
not i don't know i think it's good that
the pope
addressed this and i think it's really
shitty that the
the turkish people that not the people
but the the leaders and the government
it's like they're trying to hide
something that is very blatantly obvious
and they've been trying to hide it they
try to act like it's just a casualty of
war
and not admit that it's a genocide right
i mean 4.5
million people to me this is the most
under-reported
or under-acknowledged event that's
happened
in the last literally hundred years
which is why it's great that the pope
actually called them out on it and it's
not letting them just get away with it
and shove it under the rug like it's not
a big deal yeah if i ignore acknowledge
that but
i will also acknowledge that there are
so many more countries of color
especially in africa
where there are genocides many genocides
on a daily if not weekly basis that go
un
acknowledged by media by the church
by other foreign powers i'm thinking if
you're going to start driving
drawing lines and calling everybody call
everybody out or shut the hell up
yeah i do i mean a lot of times people
are called out but the difference is
that they're trying to hide it blatantly
and this is the anniversary so that's
why i got brought up it's not just like
a random thing
right right so is that the irony here
and that's when like the geopolitics and
religion i get it they don't work
together
really and often cause more death and
destruction than anything else
um but for a lottery a lot of the
western countries haven't acknowledged
it because they want to cozy up
to turkey uh but now turkey's been
sliding a little bit away from the west
so maybe some of these countries will
acknowledge it which then could maybe
lead to acknowledging some of the other
things that you're talking about
in africa maybe maybe i just at the end
of the day i think that when you create
um when religion becomes more divisive
than it is something that unites
yeah i mean i'm not a particularly
religious person yeah but
uh i mean let's not even get let's not
get into that
but i still feel like there's a there's
a place for religion and i think your
point was great that he's shining light
on something
and i get that that's the positive
aspect of it it's something that's been
ignored or swept under the rug for a
long time so that's the positive aspect
of it but
i don't i personally don't feel as
though religion is the place
for that is it hard for you to give
religion credit
in in cases like this even though you
did clearly there but i struggle with
that like the idea of something that
has done so much [ __ ] up [ __ ] in
general i'm just talking about
general religion um that when they do
these slow things like you're sort of a
little more okay with gays like i want
to be like
wow that's great but like they're still
like hundreds of years behind
you know what i mean yeah i mean that of
course i agree with you but i mean i
don't always want to focus on all the
bad things and of course if i
could have my way i would try to get rid
of religion because i feel like it does
more harm than good and the good that it
does do can be done without religion
but whenever they do take steps like
this of course i'm going to be happy
about it because
it overall has a positive effect on
everyone else and there are still so
many religious people
that you know this kind of thing is
almost needed all right well i don't
know that we can solve
issues of genocide and religion right
here but let us know what you think in
the comments right now